[موسيقى]
هذه هي الوجهات الأكثر إثارة وباهظة الثمن
والمرغوبة للرهبان في
العالم، يستحقها الماعز، هذا هو المكان الذي
تلتقي فيه جبال الألب بالبحر الأبيض المتوسط،
وهنا يقومون بأشياء كلها أعظم قليلاً،
مكان للتأكد من أن الأغنياء
والمشاهير يلتقون حيث  المشاهير
يطاردون السجادة الحمراء لمهرجان كانغ السينمائي
والمليارديرات يتألقون على يخوتهم الضخمة
إذا كنت تريد مشروبًا فهو
مارتيني ويجب رجه وليس
تحريكه ويفضل ذلك، لكن
كازينو مونتي كارلو تعلم أن هذا ليس نصف
سيئ الآن لا أريد ذلك  مبالغة في ذلك ولكن
الشيء المتعلق ببنات الأخ هو
أقل غطرسة قليلاً من الأماكن الأخرى في
حديقة الحيوان
وبالتأكيد فيما يتعلق بمونت كارلو، فهذه
مدينة بها وسط المدينة وبلدة قديمة وبلدة جديدة
ومناطق مختلفة ومشاعر مختلفة وأمزجة
مختلفة لطيفة كما يقولون
مختلفة
لأكثر من قرنين من الزمان،
جعل الملوك والملكات من الدازور الجيد
موطنهم الصيفي،
وشق المثقفون والفنانون
طريقهم حول الكورنيش.
وكان بابلو بيكاسو من ملوك موسيقى الروك آند رول المفضلين
مثل فرقة رولينج ستونز، حيث
انتقلوا إلى هنا في عام 1971 لتجنب
الضرائب البريطانية التي كانوا يفرضونها.  تم تسجيل المنفى في الشارع الرئيسي
في الطابق السفلي من فيلا نيلكوت
[موسيقى]
يأتي ملايين الأشخاص إلى هنا للاستمتاع
بالتجربة الفريدة لجنوب
فرنسا،
تعد الرغبة الرمزية من بين أكثر
الأماكن المرغوبة على شاطئ البحر في العالم
وهو أمر مثير للاهتمام لأن الشاطئ
نفسه  في نيس بعيدة كل البعد عن الكمال، فهي
كلها حصى وصخور على الأقل
الحفلات العامة ولكن بعد ذلك تصل إلى
الشواطئ الخاصة حيث يتوفر
كرسي للاستلقاء ومظلة وإطلالة
مثالية بالسعر المناسب
هنا، يمكنني مشاهدة إحدى
وجهات العطلات الرائعة  تعال إلى الحياة أوه نعم
لطيف لطيف جدا